Wohin fliegt eigentlich samen der fahrer
Des ersten serienautos und weltraum ist es der asteroidengürtel
Landete auf dem mars oder würde irgendwann mal
auf die erde stürzen viele von euch hatten sich das thema auch whatsapp gewünscht und was ihr euch da wünscht dauer berichte ich ja gerne
Oft da gibt es die besten themenvorschläge von euch wie er meine nummer endet das erfolgte
Am ende des videos herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction und den e on mars chroniken
Hat also allen masc noch einen letzten comics damen vor oder wird er jetzt ganz
unspektakulär durch den weltraum fliegen bis ans ende der tage erstmal
unspektakulär ist offensichtlich anders vor allen dingen zusammenhang mit dieser geschichte absolut
Untertreibung mit seinem tesla roadster als test für den erstflug der felge navy hat uns allen masc alle so richtig
Geflecht was für eine unglaubliche idee und welche unfassliche bilder das ganze noch
Gekrönt von ein wenig pop kultur mit dem hitlers guide to the galaxy an bord der musik space oddity
Von david bowie aus der stereoanlage und natürlich einem handtuch im
handschuhfach absolut irre war das aber wohin fliegt dieses ungewöhnliche raumfahrzeug jetzt eigentlich von innen musk waren bisher nur
Widersprüchliche aussagen zu hören zu mast zu mast soeben würfel und das alles scheint nicht
zu stimmen jonathan mcdowell vom harvard smithsonian center for astrophysics in cambridge, im us-bundesstaat massachusetts
Die hat die bisher bekannten daten analysiert und weiß jetzt wohin der tester unterwegs ist und eins ist sicher
daran wird sich nichts mehr ändern der
treibstoffverbrauch der kurs kann nicht mehr geändert werden
Der tesla ist nach seinen berechnungen in eine elliptische bahn rund um die sonne eingeschränkt sowie alles was hier
So im sonnensystem durch die gegend fliegt planeten asteroiden und jegliche himmelskörper dabei liegt der sonnenfenster punkt etwas
Außerhalb der mars umlaufbahn, im frühsommer wird da man dann
Den mars orbit erreichen ohne allerdings in eine umlaufbahn einzuschränken, am nächsten würde dem mars am 8 oktober
2020 seien allerdings immer noch in einer entfernung von sieben millionen kilometern viel zu weit weg um auf dem mars zu landen
einzuschlagen das wäre auch gar nicht gewünscht
Um den mars nicht mit substanzen von der erde zu verunreinigen so oder so wird der tesla wahrscheinlich viele jahrhunderte seine bahnen ziehen
Vielleicht irgendwann mal etwas abgelenkt aber eins ist sicher eine gefahr stellt er nicht da dafür ist er viel
Zu klein wurde auf die erde stürzen würde er einfach verglühen wir würden nichts davon mitbekommen auf der south by southwest
Konferenz hat muss jetzt der neue meilensteine verkündet die big falken rocket soll erste kurze flüge
Bereits in der ersten hälfte des nächsten jahres machen damit wäre das erste
interplanetaren raum schrift der menschheit absolut im zeitplan
Es wird und bleibt also spannend was wenn er als erstes neues dazu und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
Bei
Whatsapp also hier geht das dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der
redaktion vom krieg so mitmachen und mehr themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen
Und mitbestimmen was ihre klicks um so passiert denn direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau mit der glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken 1000 raketen zum mars ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran